this is Ford's blue oval it's a badge
that should be on the front of almost
every Ford vehicle but the fact that
it's been missing from some Ford
vehicles kinda points to why car prices
across the board might be going up let
me explain
wsj recently revealed that Ford delayed
deliveries on some of its trucks because
it didn't have the blue badges to go on
them now we don't know exactly how many
vehicles are awaiting blue badges but
what we do know is that Ford has said
some 40 to 45
000 of its vehicles are currently
awaiting parts and it's not just Ford
companies across the Auto industry have
suffered from Parts shortages that means
that instead of selling Vehicles they're
having to store them which is affecting
their bottom line and causing the price
of some vehicles to go up so is this a
blip our vehicle is going to be more
expensive and more prices ever come back
down let's find out
[Music]
okay let's start with what parts are in
short supply because it's not just brand
badges that are causing these holdups EV
startup Lucid had to slash its vehicle
production targets after it said it was
struggling to get hold of enough glass
and carpet for its cars by the way if
you want to see how supply chain
problems are specifically impacting EV
startups then go check out the video I
made over the summer GM also said it had
to hold shipments of around a hundred
thousand incomplete Vehicles because
they were missing parts including
semiconductors that go in everything
from the engine controls to controlling
your windows to the entertainment system
those have just been in really really
short supply for going on two years now
that's wsj Auto's editor Christina
Rogers who told me that getting hold of
Parts was only half of the problem not
only are they having trouble getting
parts but the parts are getting more
expensive just because of inflation how
much more expensive well Ford recently
announced that inflation related Supply
costs in the third quarter was costing
the company one billion dollars more
than expected everything is going up so
the suppliers are you know facing higher
commodity costs themselves and they're
in turn passing that along to their
customers and their customers happen to
be automakers so what can automakers do
to address these Rising production costs
well firstly they can create stronger
Partnerships with their suppliers like
chip makers to try and strengthen that
part of the supply chain but secondly
they can also create new relationships
with multiple suppliers of similar
products to try and Guarantee Supply I
just talked to the Volvo CEO who said
that they started dual and even triple
sourcing parts to ensure that if one
supplier has a shortage they won't just
be left paying and finally they can just
put up prices yeah sorry Ford has raised
sticker prices on the electric Mustang
Mac E SUV an F-150 Lightning truck Lucid
has said that the price of its Lucid air
is increasing GM has taxed 6250 to the
price of the GMC Hummer electric pickup
truck models and Tesla has raised the
price of a performance version of its
model y SUV three times this year and
even if a car's price doesn't go up you
still might see something different at
the dealership they're also just not
offering discounts you know this is an
industry in which in normal times you
could expect like if you walk onto a car
light you can get some kind of discount
not any more so is this a blip or our
price is going to stay high I get this
question a lot
if you're waiting for prices to come
down you could be waiting for a while
you've never seen anything like this in
the Auto industry where you've had such
a prolonged period and where prices have
been this elevated that said if there's
a big recession
I'm sure you know you'll see prices take
a hit here's the interesting thing
though even if inflation repressions go
away and automakers sort out their
supply chains Christina told me that
some of the automakers that she'd been
speaking to had said they still wanted
to keep Supply constrained and not flood
Lots with cars so low dealership stock
levels May keep car prices high for
quite some time
[Music]